معنى الانا في الاستوديو سموال المتحدث
الاقليمي باسم الخارجيه الامريكيه اهلا بك
سيد صموئيل هنا معنا في الدوحه في
الاستوديو يعني كيف نفسر هذا التصريح من
كربل الذي يقول بان وقف اطلاق النار ما
زال صامدا وان هناك اشارات جيده اي صمود
هذا واي اشارات جيده اذا اولا شكرا على
الاستضافه يا ايمان وللقناه الجزيره ونعم
نحن نراقب الامورا كثب وراينا هذه الساعات
الاخيره
الهدنه على قيد التنفيذ في بعض الاماكن
ليله الامس كان الهدنه على الاماكن في
الخرطوم ولكن راينا اليوم استانف بعض
الاشتباكات الغارات الجويه في بعض الاماكن
الاخرى في الخرطوم وايضا في اماكن مثل
شمال كردفان
وجنينه وايضا في
غرب ديرفور اذا نحن ما زال نحن نراقب
الامور نحن لدينا هذه اللجنه الجديده مع
السعوديين مع الاطراف السودانيه ونحن
سنكون في تواصل معهم في الممثلين في جده
حول اي انتحاقات اي اشتباكات التي نراها
في السودان
في تواصل معهم هناك ايضا مفاوضات جاريه
لكن مع كل الاتفاق وكل هدنه تعلن نرى عوض
التهدئه هناك تصعيد كيف تفسرون ذلك انهم
وفي نهايه المطاف لازم ناخذ الاعتبار من
يعانون من هذه الاشتباكات الشعب السوداني
ولذلك من اللازم ان نستمر بالرقم من
الصوبات المامونه بالرغم من الرافد هذه
الاطراف السودانيه لتطبيق الهدنه من
اللازم ان نستمر من اللازم ان نستمر في حث
الاطراف السودانيه ليوقف اطلاق النار فورا
لتسهيل ايصال المساعده الانسانيه لان الان
نحن نرى ان اكثر من تقريبا 800 الف
السوداني حرب ونزهوا من القتال ونحن نرى
ان ملايين من السودانيين يعانون من
الجعلان يعني هذه الارقام باتت معروفه
للجميع واشنطن تحدث عن اليه للمراقبه الان
وكانت الامل معلقه عليها كيف يمكن تنفيذ
مثل هذه الاليه والى اين وصلت نعم اذا كما
سمعنا من الاطراف لدينا الامكانيه لنراقب
بعض الاماكن عبر الاقمار الثنائيه عبر
التواصل مع الاطراف المدنيه السودانيه نحن
ما زال في تواصل مع كل الاطراف المدنيه
لان
ليس من الممكن ان نكون فقط في تواصل مع
الاطراف
قوه المسلحه الجيش السوداني وقوه الدعم
المصريه لازم نكون في تواصل مع الاطراف
المدنيه ونهن النجمه كل معلومات منها ومن
الاطراف السودانيه وايضا من الاقمار
الثنائيه
للحل سيد سامو قال يعني هل يمكن الذهاب
الى ابعد من التوصل الى اتفاقات تهدئه
ووقف اطلاق النار اذا ليس هناك اي حل عبر
العنف ليس هناك اي حل عبر القتال هنا في
السودان هذا معروف ولذلك نحن لازم نستمر
في حفل اطراف لتطبيق وقف اطلاق النار
على اقل في مده سبعه ايام ونريد ان نرى
ذلك
لاعطاء الامم المتحده الامكانيه لايصال
المساعده الانسانيه
على خطوتين لان نحن الان
نتطبق النحج خطوه بخطوه خطوه الاولى
تمديد او او تنفيذ هذه الهدره وخطوتانيه
تمديدها
تمديد هذه تنفيذ هذه الهدنه وتمديد هذه
الهدنه لكن ما هي الاوراق التي تملكها
واشنطن لتنفيذ ثم التمديد لا هذا سؤال مهم
جدا سمعنا من الوزير بلانك الوزير
الخارجيه منذ ايام هو قال ان لدينا
الامكانيه لدينا بعض الاليات وادوات مثل
القوبات مثل الضغط على الاطراف السودانيه
ولكن الان نحن ما زال في تواصل معهم كلهم
في جده نحن في تواصل مع الاطراف السودانيه
داخل السودان لان نحن نريد ان نراه تنفيذ
هذه الهدنه اليوم ولدينا هذه الادوات
لدينا امكانيه لفرد عقوبات لدينا هل
امفيديه الجديد منذ اسبوعين من البيت
الابيض من رئيس بايدن لدينا كل هذه
الادوات متاحه امامنا ولكن الان اليوم نحن
نرى هذه الاشتباكات لازم نركز على وقف
الاطلاق النار فورا
في ملف اخر سوف نستفيد من وجودك معنا هنا
في الاستوديو ايضا سيد صمو نتحدث عن هذه
الاتهامات المتبادله هذا الجدل
المتصاعد الان بين ايران واسرائيل كيف
تنظر
الى هذا الجدل هذه الاتهامات هذا التوتر
المتصاعد بين ايران واسرائيل بكل اسف هذا
التصعيد من الجانب الايراني ليس شيء جديد
الورد المتحده موقف الولد المتحده معروف
بالنسبه
ونرى هذه التحديدات من ايران امر بعض
المجموعات مثل حزب الله والى اخره وايضا
المباشره من ايران من الهرسيفوري ونحن
لدينا التواصل مفتوحه مع اسرائيل لدينا
الامكانيه للتواصل مع كل قاده
الاسرائيليين في في القدوه في واشنطن حول
اي تحديدات واي من هذه النشاط المزازه
الاستقرار من ايران
احسن ترك لوصول الى الهدف المناسب مع
ايران اترك الدبلوماسي اترك دبلوماسيه كيف
ترى واشنطن يعني افاق هذا التصعيد الحاصل
وهناك الان حديث عن يعني ضربه قد تكون
قريبه اسرائيل تتحدث عنها اليوم
وانا لا اريد اي نتيجه او دخلت في فرضيات
ليس من الممكن ان اتكلم باسم الحكومه
الاسرائيليه لدينا
الباب المفتوحه مع الاسرائيلين لنناقش كل
هذه
الملفات ولكن في نهايه الدور الذي يمكن ان
تقوم به الولايات المتحده في هذا انا كنت
اقول لك ان الولد المتحده ترى ان من
الممكن ان نتعامل مع مثلا البرنامج ناوي
الايراني عبر المفاوضات اذا رئيس بايدن هو
كان هو لن يسمعه النظام الايراني يمتلك
الاسهال النوويه وهو لن يسقط اي خيار من
الطاوله ولكن الان نحن مازال نرى ان هناك
امكانيه لوصول الى
الدبلوماسي عبر المفاوضات الدبلوماسيه
ماذا يعني تقوله اسرائيل من مستويات تخصيب
اليورانيوم
الايرانيه ما هو موقف الامريكي من ذلك من
تلك التصريحات تكلمنا عن هذا مروان
الخوف لدينا بالاسباع مستوى الاورانيه
المخصب وايضا كل النشاطات الاخرى في
البرنامج النووي الايراني وعدم تنسيق بين
الحكومه الايرانيه والوكاله الدوليه
للطاقه الازهريه هذا مهم جدا
اشكرك
المتحدث الاقليمي باسمي الخارجيه
الامريكيه